you've been all weekend you don't call
you don't write you're out there [ __ ]
around with mama i had a great weekend
what'd you do
uh not much we went to i took your
advice went to aroma yesterday which is
pretty good what'd you think of them
[ __ ] hebrews they don't [ __ ] around
down there do they no they don't it's a
little expensive it was good what'd you
get shawarma sandwich what they put on
there uh chicken shawarma with uh some
onions and uh some hummus which you
would have hated it was delicious did
you have any appetizers no no we were we
were pretty full what mama had uh she
had a like that turkey panini sandwich
they have there she loves her [ __ ]
paninis hell yeah but i had a [ __ ] up
thing happened last night this guy threw
rocks at me when i was driving home
he dinged my car wow i don't know what
happened like i was just driving home
from the store i was two seconds from my
house and i just bang bang
and it was like this older suv
and so i he pulled over so i went to go
look at his license plate and i look
like you know in california when they
have like that little paper when you
don't have a license plate yet right but
it was an older suv so i don't know why
you didn't have it used
and
as soon as i got behind him he took off
like after me like he he i was behind
him and he took off so i started chasing
him but then he got behind me and
started chasing me
so i like i had to go into a side street
turn my lights off and i have a gate in
my parking area so i turned my lights
off and i snuck in and i didn't get out
of the car until the gate closed again i
was i didn't know what that i was kind
of upset at myself i was like maybe i
should have got out of the car or thrown
so i i didn't know what to do so we
talked about it a while ago how like i
need to i i i
don't like confrontation
and uh
but we were just talking about earlier i
talked uh this week
and i just i had a conversation with you
just you know it's not even a bad
conversation it it's just something that
i'm not good
when it's a serious conversation that
like
above like me starting my podcast the
real reason i haven't started it is
because in the over the past year i've
had
two or three podcasts that i'm no longer
with or that aren't going anymore
and i'm i don't like when things don't
work
it's like i was basically being scared
of failing
and it was just it was [ __ ] up so i
was feeling bad about myself last night
like i couldn't go to bed thinking i
should have stood up for myself or but i
don't i don't know what that [ __ ] was
gonna do if he's throwing stuff on my
car yeah
yeah he's having a bad day he's looking
to mess somebody else's day right you're
a sweetheart of a guy he threw a rock in
your car so unless you got a [ __ ]
cannon or bazooka in your car yeah or a
[ __ ] flamethrower
you know i i don't advise people getting
that especially you know
it's unless you take one of john lewis's
mma course then you know what the [ __ ]
you want you know flying out of the car
and stars and [ __ ] everything what's
going on my brother john lewis oh man
how are you doing man thanks for having
me good to see you yeah man you're doing
great things like you know everybody i
talked tonight john little john lewis
around here no [ __ ] so i said people
want to [ __ ] talk to john lewis
little [ __ ] [ __ ] the gentleman here
we are man what's happening little
brother it's going good it's going good
what are you doing oh man just uh doing
my thing you know being out here opening
a new school and just
just getting it going man you know
acting and all of it sometimes [ __ ] with
peter yeah that was fun unbelievable
i've put it on the one thing there you
are like what the [ __ ] that you guys
shot yeah right [ __ ] arab shot they
always shoot everybody's thinking
he's getting the head cut caved in like
everyone else at least
what about this man did you audition for
that yeah yeah
yeah yeah definitely
for producers yeah yeah the whole
sessions double callback whole nine
yards i thought you got it like as a
stunt man like a lot of times i go on
sets and i see martial artists i know
yeah it's not my interest i'm like what
the [ __ ] are you doing here like we're
doing stunts
we're doing the fight scenes or whatever
so they throw you like a roll on it yeah
you know you laugh but most of the
things that i've done so far have been
like romantic comedies and i think i
threw one kick and one show so far
everything has been dramas and romantic
comedies and that kind of thing so i a
lot of the guys now from the ufc they
get the free pass they they're winning
to win their title and they
automatically getting called for shows
but i retired 10 years ago so for me
that it has nothing to do with my my
acting career
you know i was friends with joe for a
long time he would tell me about mma so
i went home one night i came from cuba i
saw bruce lee you know i came from cuba
a year later bruce lee came on the scene
so i came up with that mindset i i
joined kung fu you know renato laranja
yeah his father was my first karate
teacher in new york city
so i you know i trained with the [ __ ]
cottagers and the forums and everybody
was in great shape and all of a sudden
they're telling me what's this ufc and i
put and i put on i see tank ab in the
wrestling suit and i'm like i'm not
watching this [ __ ] you know no offense
to tank ad but i was just expecting
these you know chinese guys flying
through the [ __ ] air and stuff so i
never watched it again until one night i
turned on uh
something and i saw anderson silva go
through chris liebman
and i go i gotta see what the [ __ ] this
is about it's been hooked ever since i
got a man yeah i mean it's that's a
story for a lot of people when they said
that forrest griffin versus a bonner
fight bonafide that changed the game for
a lot of people who weren't fans well it
was just weird to see these guys and you
know at first you'd see like a jiu jitsu
guy and not [ __ ] jiu-jitsu
you gotta go like to brooklyn to a
brazilian neighborhood to learn jiu
jitsu with new york city and nobody had
i remember talking to matt sarah and he
was telling me that when he first
started jiu jitsu he would have to take
a bus on sundays from long island yeah
to red bank new jersey because that's
the only place we had jiu jitsu on
sundays so they would drive three hours
basically to train
one hour and a half and then go right
back to the [ __ ] three hours and
now it's everywhere jiu jitsu is like
dog [ __ ] you know you go to
next year they'll have jiu-jitsu onyx
where you jump up and down i think they
already have some old jujitsu guy from
the year 2000 how did you get into all
this because you're from hawaii yeah
yeah born and raised in hawaii actually
uh left when i was 17. uh we can get to
all that stuff but as far as your
specific question i don't know as i was
fighting my whole life hawaii is a place
that you grew up fighting and that's a a
place that you can actually build status
uh as being a street fighter a good
fighter and me even though i was born
there i wasn't you know i'm not hawaiian
i'm not vocal per se meaning of the of
the majority racist polynesian looking
so
you know at a young age you know um me
being half black half white we'd get you
know racial slurs or things would happen
and i would always be quick to fight and
i'd always do well and i you know
somewhere around my fifth and sixth
grade year i beat up a couple of
big name bullies in in the area and all
of a sudden the same people that were
you know weren't digging on me all of a
sudden started
like liking me and being coming and so
that was my first like uh i guess it was
my first introduction into seeing how if
you're really good at something
people's perspectives change of you you
know when i was young so it mattered you
know so at that time uh
i i wasn't the punk ever i was always
defending people i was always you know
beating up the bullies or whatever but
at the same time
you know i became more and more popular
in hawaii and i that became a way of
life for me is just uh being being a
fighter you know at the same time i was
dancing believe it or not breakdancing
street dancing and all that stuff
uh on a professional level and growing
and doing shows there and everything and
uh and then when i got to the age of uh
i think was 17 i had an opportunity to
come to the california to audition for a
big show that
ended up being in vegas and we can get
to that but yeah but but it brought me
out of hawaii and that was where my
foundation was training some martial
arts there as well but really my
mentality of just fighting and
wanting to experiment and see how good i
could get
because i was doing very well as it was
as a natural street fighter so i started
dabbling in martial arts and just what
was the first world show that you walked
into it was like
which is like um japanese kickboxing
it's basically muntai you know um so
stand-up system you know and i was and i
just had good hands i was fast couldn't
hit me you know and uh and that combined
with the with that it just it just
kept going and i just kept wanting to
get better wanting to get better i
wanted to see what what holes i had in
my game and i would just put myself out
there in scenarios to see you know to
test myself and it just grew this is all
before the way before the sport you know
i mean 93 was when the ufc hit denver
colorado so we're talking way before all
this and it just kind of transitioned
into all of it
and why is hawaii such like
uh one of my dear friends is earl
uh whatever his name is cooper a black
dude a sifu earl and he was telling me
the history of something like kajikembo
where i guess the hawaiians were always
smaller so there was a naval base there
yeah so these guys have to you know they
would have to fight these [ __ ]
americans that were yoked up you know
these [ __ ] midwest [ __ ]
would come in there after eating steak
and potatoes so hawaiians really worked
on their fighting styles and one of them
was kaiju kimbo which is judo yeah
eastern boxing or western boxing yeah
they love boxing they love boxing and uh
it's just amazing that there's a there's
a system out of hawaii and kaja kimbo
breaks into like four different systems
like there's a kung fu influence one
there's a harder one you know in l.a
they have the brothers
that really refined it they call it like
a kenpo you know but it's why is it such
a fighting environment there it's really
funny man um
i mean it's just as a warrior a warrior
i mean hawaiians polynesians you know
someone's
that that whole uh
that whole you know it's all a very
warrior-based people
so i think there's a pride a proud
proudness of pride there there's a pride
there if you're really good at fighting
and just combat in general and being a
warrior and um
the funny thing about it is even there
if you were in those days if you were to
grab someone and fall on the ground uh
it would be you'd be looking look bad
they'd say they'd say up and up up and
up which means get back up on your feet
you know like hands to hand and nobody
would jump in there was nobody trying to
stick you with knives from behind uh you
know we used to fight uh when every
wednesday we'd meet with another school
called lalihua another competitive
school near to us and we'd meet under
this bridge area every friday i mean
every wednesday and it would be because
that's the half day of school short day
of school and it would be i'mma fight
you that i'm fighting you and everybody
would circle around and it would be a
fair fight nobody would jump in fist
fight if you go on the ground you back
up back up back up and you just fight
you know you you scrap you call it you
know so it's like
it's just it's just the nature of the
beast over there it's crazy you have a
smile on your face when you're talking
about it and that sounds like the most
terrifying thing in the world no it's
it's really wonderful man there's
nothing more to me there's nothing
better than than that it's like really
putting yourself out there exposing
yourself and really seeing what you're
made of you know and a lot of the times
my best friends ended up being i'm sure
everybody can say this being guys they
fought when they're young because it's
such an intimate thing to be to be so
exposed and to at the end of the fight
to be very clear that you lost or you
won
so you can't say nothing i mean it's
like
you're great you know and then usually
you become friends with the guys because
it's it's an intimate experience to
fight somebody you know it's just a
different level when you
remember coming from cube and going to
karate then get into a couple fights and
where your mind goes yeah like it
happens so [ __ ] quick as a kid you
know where your mind goes
and then as i got older you know bruce
lee came and we go to the movies and we
get the little tussles
and i liked it for a while it's when i
started getting old i didn't like it
once i got into like in my teens i love
throwing my hands i love getting smacked
you know it's it's funny how you say
that sometimes you fight like the kid
that saved my the kid i moved in with my
mother died beat me up
two years before that we got into a fist
fight and we beat up and he broke my
nose i hit him in the head you know he
bled from his eye but he beat me up he
got the best of me and when my mother
died he came to me because i want you to
move my house so it's correct
you you take your friendship to such a
level i mean it's not even a friendship
we weren't friends and we became friends
the next day it was like a thing of
respect
but uh
i just didn't like i liked the martial
art angle of it but it got real
once i got to high school it got a
little too real like a sticker come out
or a knife could come out and that's
what
that's a completely different level but
i understand what you're saying yeah
with two kids fist fight nobody can jump
in there's no knives they hover around
you
and after uh eight nine minutes you look
at each other and go like man it's over
you shake hands and you go to school the
next day nobody says nothing to you you
know people nobody says nothing to you
they want people to really want to see
who is who's the better between the two
fighters they don't want you to
use a stick or a knife because they
really want to see who's better and they
and the and the cl and you know the
student follows the like we do with what
boxers or fighters these days you know
one day you're like so-and-so sucks then
he wins a couple times and he's your
favorite and then he loses then he's
overrated it's that's you know you
follow the that you follow the winner
you know so in those days
i found you know be the winner be the
winner and you uh and you get friends
how did your parents react when you were
coming home with like black eyes and
stuff i wasn't the other guy was
i could answer no i mean i have a couple
things every now and then but for the
most part i mean i was winning you know
so
uh and a couple times i'd have other
injuries and i would say i fell off my
bike or whatever but it wouldn't change
anything because it come come the next
day you don't want to gotta go to school
and you're the one who got to deal with
the people so you know funny thing
though in high school my mother was a
campus walker so half the fights i got
in were defending my mother whose job
was to make sure things were okay and
i'm like somebody's voicing off to her
so i i you know so it ended up being
actually helped me fight even more the
fact that she was there so it was
interesting so you're you're a kid in
hawaii
the first school you walk into japanese
kickboxing yeah yeah and you're also
break dancing at the same time yes
donnie dee's on the back up right all
that [ __ ] doing
so
you graduated high school though no i
didn't i didn't i should [ __ ] yeah i
left what happened was i had an
opportunity um for a specific show in
las vegas called splash at the riviera
hotel which at the time i'm talking
about
um guys i don't even know but you know a
long time ago and it was the popular
hotel was a nice hotel back in the day
um and it was like there's an audition
for this thing a girlfriend of mine who
lived out here already told me to come
out and uh give it a shot so it was one
of those things like you know which of
course everybody tells you you know
finish school you know which i'm
definitely i'm an advocate of you know
my son making sure he's finished in
school but i left uh i told my mother
say mom i want to go do this i want to
this is what i want to do you know so
she was really supportive you know i had
a good childhood as far as you know
parents supporting what i did you know
those kind of sad stories it was had a
good upbringing that way um you know it
was low low income but love was there
you know and the support was there so i
uh
i she put me on a plane we flew to
california by myself you know stayed at
a friend's place crashed on the floor
and never went back you know and uh and
continued to climb the ladder from then
on you know as a dancer versus a dancer
i got the audition we got it got in the
show um called splash in the river hotel
uh
was there for
about two almost three years at 17 years
old you know for me coming out living
with my mom to have my own space having
what i thought was a lot of money per
week and i was just living in a hotel
had to be the run of the hotel it was
just a very very big change got into all
kinds of trouble that you could imagine
at that age with uh drugs and everything
else nothing that was like you know put
me out but it was things you know things
you dabble with when you're young and
all my friends were older in a nightlife
kind of environment and it was very
interesting but a couple years later you
know i moved on to
i started doing music
and i started writing the music and my
girl got a piano and she she bought it
in the house i just i started playing it
and i learned to play with myself and
six seven months i was playing pretty
good and just taught myself to play then
i started writing music
and uh from there i i i said you know
i'm kind of bored of doing this i think
i want to go be a rock star so then i i
i
shortly after
quit the job uh which was doing well and
packed and moved to california
um
met another couple other like-minded
people started doing my thing and uh got
produced by a gentleman named jerry haye
who's a very very big producer um the
horn arrangement for michael jackson and
quincy jones and everything and a little
bit after that we got to deal with the
lecture records he got signed uh did
that whole thing yeah you pull it down
yeah yeah what the [ __ ] is the name of
the album let's play this game no you
can't find it these days pop school was
the band me and me and my buddy steve
silva he was the lead singer and yeah
and um
and then uh and still i mean i was
writing for a long time after that
and then during all that i was also
fighting and then i fought won a title
and then i had a choice of what do i
want to do do i want to
you know even though you get a record
deal it's like it's like acting yeah i'm
an actor yeah i got a job and then a
year later you're still trying to
audition right so you get a record deal
you get you know you finish your album
it's so much more than getting a record
deal to become successful artist and i
was succeeding in fighting
professionally
so i made a decision to um to let that
go and focus on the fighting and
move to vegas and
open my school in 95.
all right so now
you're [ __ ] beautiful
so now you're in you're in vegas now you
get to vegas you're 17. are you training
at all
uh i am still training yeah where are
you training in vegas just like with a
friend of mine named nick one kick one
of my buddies out there he's still a big
name out there yeah he's one kid because
he knocks guys out with the kick when he
kicked it in and uh just you know just
doing that kind of thing and um before i
moved to vegas i jumped i jumped really
along because before i moved to vegas
was all the gracie training and the and
a little bit of the machado training so
you were doing gracie training in hawaii
no no when i moved can i move from there
to here first okay here to vegas to do
the show all right back to la as an
actor i mean as a musician and that's
when i started trying oh okay when you
were in that way
gracie and i did that for a while and
then uh
i got i got kicked out of that school
when i fought carlson gracie jr so they
uh let me go because i was fighting one
of the cousins and became the first uh i
mean it was considered a draw because
there were there were no uh
no judges this in those days you had to
either knock them out or submit them or
to draw but i dominate the fight clearly
but so it was like the first person to
open the eyes that gracie could be beat
because up until then hoist was this
cleaning house in the ufc
um so um that was like instantly
launched me into a different position uh
in the indica new community because it
was on pay-per-view so people could see
it
and we were fighting with no gloves it
was 30 minutes straight yeah
i mean you can google this on youtube
yes
30 minutes straight yeah no rhymes yeah
yeah no rounds yeah you know but it was
it was okay you know you just paced
yourself through the fight and yeah and
and that was that was where it really
launched my my real martial art
professional career because that put me
on the map right right up until then i
was like who's this guy he's going to
get killed and i didn't and that changed
a lot for me
you know
and now you tr you train them with
channels after the graces because i got
kicked out of the gracies
it was carlos and it was a roger i'd see
higgin a lot up in june the bell spot um
and higgins was great
he's a great martial artist
um but you walked into gene labella
white belt judo i did i did yeah yeah
i'm john perretti a friend of mine
brought me to meet gene and uh and me
and gene hit it off
and i trained with him up in the cabin
you know
and that was great
uh i don't know what happened from the
edit so i'd see he got up there training
rolling with the guys dominating
everybody he was powerful powerhouse
young and just powerful
and then um
and from there it just keeps going man
well [ __ ] keep going tell me what
happened after that well um
yes i would go to machado school
and uh that was cool for a moment now
you're a blue belt during all this with
machado yeah yeah yeah blue belt but
i've been a blue boat for a while
because i didn't have a home at that
point you know as you see those guys
who've been a one belt for a long amount
of time you know and i'm also a black
girl from uh
from jean around that time or almost
about jail about stage yeah judo yeah
that's his first i was his first black
belt white to black and he's trained
everybody from bruce lee to
to uh i mean benny the jet and chuck
norris but but i was you know they'd
come in and learn from him but i really
was a disciple from the beginning
yeah so that's really a cool honor to
say you know and also as a jujitsu i was
the fourth american uh black belt in the
world to get a black belt brazilian jiu
jitsu what american and who'd you get
your black male from from andre
pedinaires now how does he come into the
picture now andre um after fighting the
gracies um another mutual friend of ours
who passed um
he
you know he's a brazilian guy he knew
andre was doing something over there in
brazil doing really really well
and he just brought him over to the
states to meet me and said maybe we can
do something together because i needed
that kind of support to grow you know
and no one really wanted to teach me
after i fought the uh both you know the
gracies
not any brazilians were really trying to
help because it was threatening the
the mystique you know and this guy was
open-minded guy they said man i just
you're good and you're a nice guy let's
work together
and you he got me up there real quick he
trained with me hard we would go to
brazil and stay in brazil for a while
and i and i'd fight he'd corner all my
fights and coach me and i uh we'd come
back and forth and um eventually i got a
black belt from andre
and uh
he launched the school launched a team
called nobunyo which is
basically means new union
but it's one of the biggest teams in the
world right now top five teams in the
world we have 416 schools
and um
i was the president of nova now for the
united states i brought it it was only
in brazil i brought it from brazil to
the united states and like i say now
almost 20 years later there's 416
different schools you know that are i
don't just mean like you buy the
affiliate but i mean guys it went from
under us to black belts you know and
this spread and their black belt spread
and it's continues to go up um so i mean
andre and that was really the best for
me because he was not holding things
back there was no
you know it was just this is what you
need to get to the next level this is
what you need to get to the next level
which is how i learned to teach the way
that i teach if people train with me
they realize there's no like um i don't
have any pace as far as holding people
back it's just pretty much i can look at
you i can see what you got i can see
what you need and i can show you
something right then that will make you
better right then you know i literally
say you know
one class with me is like training a
month with someone else or anywhere else
why is that because of that exact reason
i know how to i know how to articulate
the
what you need
i know how to show you it show you what
you need and i can see what you need i'm
not just coming there with an agenda of
of this you know especially especially
in a private situation where this is
just a move you're going to learn i
wrestle with you the whole class i'm on
the ground with you getting sweaty
working out and uh i can feel you you
know and i can say this is what you got
to do and by the time that class is over
your game will be held elevated and i
show techniques like that all the time
and a lot of times they're very simple
uh strategic concepts or positions that
people are like
man you know i i i never understood that
you know something you know someone can
show you something in acting you know
what i'm talking about someone can you
can go to acting classes and try to get
this one thing and then you can meet
this one probably usually another actor
who can just tell you something and all
of a sudden it's like
oh you know like why didn't you ever say
so you know but it's just the way some
people can articulate things better than
others and i think that's a gift that i
have i'm able to articulate
my thoughts and what i'm trying to get
out to someone
across the board not only martial arts
just that's just one of the things i'm
good at now your
mentor panerais yeah
now who was his because that was was
interesting one i want to ask you when
we spoke on the phone and we spoke in
your class one day
that he was here gracie guy or a machado
guy himself
he is uh his black his blackball comes
from um
the late uh uh whatever
would i fight as uh junior junior
college uh cam jim brenda blank the guy
that i fought fish gracie no i fought
junior carlson carlson gracie jr his
father was carlos and gracie the past
recently right that was his black belt
that was his black yeah yeah and then
from him was the source you know so it's
the lineage is strong you know just so
it's basically
the founder you guys
yeah
how important is it for a ufc fighter
because i just i just got into it about
a couple years ago and it's he it's when
you're watching it it seems like a
one-on-one this guy versus that guy
sport but when you're saying like top
five school
how important is it when you're like as
a fighter joey you've been to like four
or five different jiu-jitsu coaches even
as a amateur how important is it like
what school to go to or what camp to be
a part of it's really important because
um well first of all it's
most of all finding a teacher that
you're you can vibe with that you enjoy
to learn from you know number one to one
that really cares about teaching and
they really uh
doesn't want to just make the money but
really wants to help you get better
and uh and then just if you just got to
make sure you can you mesh with that
person you know but you know sometimes
if you get to the wrong teachers i mean
they can teach you the wrong things as
simple as that they can show little
details they miss or or they can show
you techniques without the details that
when you try to do it you're like man
it's not working for me you know it's
not working for me but then all of a
sudden someone else can show you just
one little oh because you didn't turn
your hip like i mean literally you
didn't turn your hip like this and all
of a sudden the move is totally
different and brazilian jiu jitsu is
like that it's it's a kind of situation
where you
have to do all the little details and if
you understand the movement of the body
and and where you should be and where
your weight should be the move can
totally change if i'm if i'm over
somebody just i'm just going to use a
random concept if someone's under me and
i'm over them
if i'm right here i'm pretty wobbly you
know because they can throw me either
direction based on the technique from
right here i'm heavy to lift this
direction you know so if someone can
show you a move about passing you know
we call patching the guard getting
around the guy's legs you know but
they're they're in the wrong place
you'll try it on your friend and your
friend will throw you over and a few
times later you're like this doesn't
work you know but that's just because
you weren't here you just you went from
here to here and all of a sudden he
can't move you so those are the details
that um takes a teacher that really has
the patience and
want for you to really understand the
details and that's how i teach i i want
you to learn you know exactly i mean
you're a reflection on me you know my
black belt's a reflection on me are you
allowed to as a fighter go from camp to
camp to learn different things that's a
that's up to the teachers i personally
advocate it i don't mind at all
i'd like my like my students to
represent me when they're competing so
we're under one banner but i have no
problem with people going and
experimenting because i always i grew up
that way going to different schools i
have black belts from many different in
arts and that's part of why i'm good so
for me to tell someone they shouldn't
would be kind of hypocritical um you
know i love the loyalty of the of my
student to to know that you know i'm i'm
where they get their belt from they
don't jump and get belts from you know
blue for me and purple from him and you
know but please go out and experiment
and maybe even bring something back that
you can share
it's amazing how this is an art
you know i hate when people call
themselves artists that drives me
[ __ ] crazy
but
all these arts go hand in hand how much
does jujitsu
and judo help your music
how much does it enlighten it for you
just by when i leave dave and dave just
went over an armbar with me and i'm
driving up laurel canyon and my mind's
going about that arm bar
jesus christ i learned it over here he
was right i didn't you know dave taught
me i could not borrow anybody yeah
awesome damn girl you gotta get on the
[ __ ] angle you're trying to harm
mommy from in front of you what the [ __ ]
are you doing who taught you this turned
this far yeah this far and also you're
like what the [ __ ] that's what i'm
talking about but that i
what people don't seem to understand
like somebody emailed me a month ago
about you know when you go to this they
send you all these math
classes i go that's to make your mind
analytical you dumb [ __ ]
you know your wife is an attorney her
pre-attorney she had to take a [ __ ]
ton of math classes and ask her right
calculus and [ __ ] what's calculus got to
do with [ __ ] suit somebody for
slipping on the
opens your stairs
and i know for a [ __ ] fact that yeah
whatever i've done comedy for a long
time but ever since i joined jiu jitsu
my comedy went somewhere else ever seen
ever since i saw mma and i became a fan
of certain fighters
i it made me stronger because i would
get pissed off because they didn't learn
something from the last fight so if i'm
smacking you with a [ __ ] left jab
jesus christ the whole last fight and
this guy saw that tape i hope that you
learn how to [ __ ] protect away from
that left jab maybe to work to your
right or put your [ __ ] opposite hand
up higher when i see a fighter come in
and do the same [ __ ] and then start
throwing spinning back punches that move
gets my blood pressure
[ __ ]
but
when you just come in and do the same
[ __ ] and think because you're doing a
spinning backhand that i'm supposed to
fall off my chair and then you get beat
up yeah i think i stand up and i think
i'm like you're going to go up there
with that same stupid [ __ ] joke
really you got some bear [ __ ] balls
get you know
it's helped me it's helped me and
did it help you with your music it's
funny
i'm not even going to say with the music
but i'm just going to say in general
lifewise like i'm the kind of guy that
um that
i mean i've launched many different
careers as well as you'll find out over
there our conversation and and i'm the
kind of guy that just you go and you
just you go you came 100 and i was just
this morning speaking about the very
thing you're talking about
and i said um to someone that
when before i get in the fight i i'm i
mean i'm getting ready for it i'm
training for it i'm all amped up you get
to backstage for six hours or so before
the match starts and then eventually
closer gets the butterflies start you
know i've never they always were there
you know no matter how much how many
times i've fought always nervous always
nervous and it's healthy as long as it's
healthy if you control it it's healthy
right you know you don't let it consume
you because we all have what you said
earlier which is this fear of failure we
all have this the difference is some
people can take it and and make it power
another is to let it beat them and
freeze them you know which is the stage
fright concept so in this situation you
know you get backstage and you got
butterflies you're nervous you know and
but you're like oh man i got to do this
and you start kind of you're getting
hyped up and you're moving backstage you
know they call your name you start
walking out in front of all these these
thousands and people and millions
watching you on tv and and you're
nervous you know but once you step in
the cage and the door shuts this is
always what i say to myself
okay i'm in the cage now there's no
turning back i can get out so i may as
well win
because he's gonna he's gonna try to
take my head off or i have to take his
head off at this point there's no other
choices so that's how i look at life
it's like when you pick something and
you commit to something and you go that
direction once you're in you're in you
know once you step on the stage it's all
comedy
if you back off your differences you
lost you lost so you you're here now you
might as well just let it all go
and go out like a man or or win like a
man so that mentality of
i tell myself i'm in the cage now
there's no might as well win i'm in the
cage i might as well win don't [ __ ]
about what you're doing you know you're
in the cage so i can either win or i can
lose i think i'll win with all the
technology they have
and martians and [ __ ] spaceships the
only [ __ ] thing i want them to make
is a thought thing that i can see
because this is what makes my dick hard
is you know what you just described the
five minutes before you throw that punch
when [ __ ] dean looks at you or john
mccarthy looks at you and says you're
ready you're ready when you walk back to
that ring backwards
what the [ __ ] is in your mind the same
thing when i get to a thing hey man
what's up john oh [ __ ] the flying jews
here how's the audience the audience
great
and you're killing and you're killing
but once lee comes off that's when it's
real yeah once league comes off in the
emcee it's real this [ __ ] is
still talking to me about his wife and
about his kids and it's bouncing off you
right they don't realize that
your mind is just seeing [ __ ] battle
and all of a sudden you go up you you
whatever your shirt you pop your because
your ball stuck to your leg you pop it
off
and they say your [ __ ] name and
that's what i want to see
that's what i want to see i want to see
that as they come the pop-up you ever
watch like vh1 pop-up videos i want to
see all the things in your head
i want to see all that because for me
it's [ __ ] tremendous i i love it yeah
i love it
that that's that fear every and i tell
people i tell him all the time listen
whatever [ __ ] you see on stage when
i get in my car to drive to that gig i
think of every [ __ ] excuse in the
world because that's what you naturally
do that's what your mind naturally does
why am i doing this i'm a loser i'm
gonna get a job tomorrow this sucks why
am i 50 still doing stand-up i should be
a [ __ ] director you know you get all
the and the closer you get to laurel
canyon and once i make that left onto
the lord canyon oh
that's when everything comes out that's
what it's in full volume you're a loser
you did this your mother sucks it just
and then you then once you hit laurel
cane you're like [ __ ] i'm going down
there i'm just like not gonna take the
beat that's when you forget all your
jokes it's true you have no [ __ ]
ideally how many times have i called you
from a place that said lee what jokes do
i say tonight you're not even a [ __ ]
guy no matter how much you practice how
much you practice doesn't matter it just
goes away like every couple weeks you
call me people don't [ __ ] understand
and then you get there and they say your
name and that's a different process and
all of those feelings all that i just
told you those 18 20 minutes
is a ball and it just keeps spinning and
something as soon as i grab that
microphone
like what's up [ __ ]
that's it it all comes one it becomes
one yeah just because one i just become
hard you know i used to do comedy fees i
didn't give a [ __ ] now when i do two
shows when i get back to my room john
and i take a shower when i come out it's
like i roll for [ __ ] 15 minutes my
whole body hurts i become a [ __ ]
savage i can feel that energy going from
your toes to adrenaline nothing no
commitment it's it's commitment that
that's got to be that's the worry it's
coming close to it's the same i think
everything in life is the same i think
we you can wrap up life as a whole in
that little sentence we just said about
once you're in the cage you might as
well win
because you're in the cage anyway to
people following their dreams and
quitting the jobs or even just being at
a new job like right out of college and
like being nervous maybe i should go
move back with my parents and work at
the movie theater again it's all those
thoughts the difference is some people
actually give up and do those things and
other people say
[ __ ] it you know i'm just gonna go with
it so how do you describe
like the adrenaline drop that sometimes
happens like is it is it them not
preparing or is it just is it just
natural that when you start something
new that you're gonna fall a little bit
like when you see that happen what do
you think when you say adrenaline drop
at what stage do you like when they when
they're like first fighting the ufc the
cage what i forget what rogan's term for
is yeah i mean
well there's there's a little bit of uh
overwhelming i mean this could happen in
in every entertainment industry you can
think of as well when you're you know
you're put out there you're really there
and that's the difference between the
men and the boys you know and sometimes
that's that's the difference there's a
very small group of men and there's a
lot of boys in in acting and anything
else that you do because when you you
know you want it so bad you kind of
finally get there and when you're there
you're just one you're not probably not
ready because you didn't prepare
properly which is key and everything and
acting and training whatever just
preparing yourself properly and two is
you find out what you really got what
you are is this really for me you know
you know when you're when you're in a
fight and you're getting hit in the face
you know i learned the best from fights
that i lost you know you don't learn
from one and you learn from losing and
uh some of the best fights i've had have
been fights that i have lost
and the reason why is because you know i
like for instance 16 minutes in the
fight when i'm getting hit in the face
over and over and over all i can think
of is
i'm going to win i just got to get this
i just got to get i just got to get i'm
one i never think i'm going to lose i
think i'm going to win
from the outside it's like damn he's
getting his face punched in from my
perspective is like i'm a little hit me
in the face so i can get his ankle like
i'm thinking i'm going to win until next
time you know a tko happens where they
just referee stops you and says you're
getting hit too much but but but when i
leave that five point wow man i was
really truly ready to die at that moment
and not wanting to die i didn't think i
thought i was gonna win until i lost and
that's when you can look back and go i
learned something about myself and that
is something that no matter what you do
in life um that's who you are and some
people don't have that some people look
for the they're they when they're
winning they're killing it but when
someone starts putting the pressure on
them and they can't take it that's when
you see them fold and that's who they
are as well how much of it do you think
for the for ufc fighters is
technique that they've learned and then
just like the other side is like them as
a human and
they're they're well willpower
how much of that makes a successful
fighter do you think well first of all i
think major majority of it is uh is
conditioning and being in shape because
if you're not in shape no matter how
good you are when that fatigue hits you
know it makes mice and men you know it's
you got to be able to fight past that
fatigue but um i think it's just pretty
much just being prepared 100 prepared um
and
being able to to weather the storm
there's a guy uh you guys all should all
know named frank shamrock
he was a great fighter because if you
see he'd have fights that was a really
great fight with him and tito ortiz
and it was the one in the ufc where tdo
was dominating he was you know one of
the guys that i trained um he was great
he fought him three times yes yes three
times
i know i remember a couple times maybe i
don't even remember but it was this
first one that one tita was was you know
bigger stronger and he was dominating
frank for the whole most of the fight
you know but
he once again he just kept trying kept
trying kept going kept going and in the
end tito made the mistake and he got out
and he was able to finish and tito was
tired and he was able to finish that
fight because
that's the difference is like no matter
how
how bad how down you are you know you
haven't lost until you lost
you know and a lot of people
you know once they feel that losing
happening they just accept it that they
lost and that's it they did lose because
the mind changes and you become the
loser at that moment
but
the greats are the ones that just
still think they're going to win you
know
denial or whatever you want to call it
they're they're they're going to win
they just got to figure out when their
chance to win is whether they wanted a
loss at the end of the fight to me they
won because when you can come give you
everything give your best give
everything that you got you can go home
that day and you know you want you wish
you won but you can go home and go and i
did the best i could do nothing is worse
than going into there going
well why did i i knew i could have went
longer but i let the guy submit me or i
i tapped cause i was tired or you know
that's when that's the stuff you can
live with that'll carry you they'll be
last 25 years in your mind after that
fight
after i started stand up my life changed
because that's where my mind went
it went to a place of danger and i liked
danger
i was a criminal you know i like
carrying a gun and climbing through
somebody's window and kicking the door
and seeing if they got an ounce or a
kilo or coke
i like that danger in my life i did i
really liked it that's
what got my dick hard you know then when
you get in the car and you're driving
you're like somebody could have got a
shot in that [ __ ] room
it could have been me or i could end up
getting 30 [ __ ] years for stupidity
right so as i was trying to get my life
back together i got to stand up and just
that rush that whole thing like it
overwhelmed everything you know i think
of now how i got off the drugs
and i got out of that mindset and it was
all through stand-up comedy yeah it
really [ __ ] was just taking chances
and once i was in i was in
like in 1991 i thought i wanted to do
stand-up i got on stage and i [ __ ]
around with it for two years and i tell
people this all the time when they send
me emails i didn't take to it right away
it was everybody else you suck
i [ __ ] sucked
you know i sucked i had to talk to the
audience i sucked
but then in 93 one 94 once 93 93 and a
half 94 came i'm like i'm going for this
i have nothing else i'm 30 something
years old i have nothing else going on
i'm not going to use my [ __ ] degree
i'm not going to [ __ ] i got felonies
they're not going to hire me as a stock
broker i'm not going to sell insurance
didn't we check and see in [ __ ]
colorado if you have a felon you can't
even be an acupuncturist i couldn't do
[ __ ] i wouldn't i don't give a [ __ ] you
know me i walk in and deny it till the
end that i got fellas i don't have no
[ __ ] i don't know what you're talking
about but it was really the [ __ ]
stand up because that kind of
that getting your ass kicked every night
and going back to this you know how many
times i cried myself to sleep i have to
stand up
as a man
i hear you because it wasn't going well
or
sure
sure you're in a [ __ ] hotel in moscow
idaho and you just bombed at a [ __ ]
college and you're giving you 50 bucks
and you owe on the rent then you owe 600
on child support and you you your kid
hates you your wife hates you your
girlfriend's sucking somebody else's
dick and this is what happens and now
but in the morning you wake up and you
go
my kid can hate me
my wife can hear me i can own the rent
but one thing i could control is i get
on stage and i do a lot better than what
i did last night right you have control
of that broke as [ __ ] getting living off
a subway veggie and cheese sandwich
and saying [ __ ] it i'm gonna go
you know what
you know what tomorrow go get a job
tonight i'm gonna go [ __ ] do a lot
better than what i did last night but
the probably gonna generally quit comedy
but then you do so well that night
that you go [ __ ] i just bought myself
another [ __ ] month yeah and i get it
and i've transformed that attitude to
jitsu like a lot you know when i first
started youtube we had the schools a lot
of young kids they're killing me they're
[ __ ] killing me they're my cardio
stuff then i started working and i
started saying you know what all i want
to do is go in their last two minutes
today
and have the last two minutes i leave
there like the king of [ __ ] pressure
right because you're competing with
yourself yeah you're not competing with
that person no but you're better than
you were yesterday yeah that's what
mattered that's it that that's it listen
if i did that went for an armbar against
somebody i was laughing my [ __ ] i
didn't even have the right arm didn't
matter
i went for the [ __ ] arm bar you know
why because what am i going to do not go
for it until i get it how i'm going to
learn is by going for it how many times
do i tell you when i suck ass and work
on the car driving home
and you'll say yeah that joke didn't
work and i go it don't matter
i said that thing on stage to let you go
what thing and i'm saying i'm saying
that thing it didn't work but i said it
well
you you you're saying exactly what i
said what you're saying is
i'm in the cage anyway so i might as
well win and that's when you and by the
way when you started explaining this
whole thing you know you started talking
about the first part of your career in
sucking and you had you kept coming back
that's great but you know a lot of
fighters continue to lose and accept
being losers just want to make some
money and keep coming back that's not it
yet it's when you said i'm 37 and blah
blah blah that's when you stepped in the
cage you said you know what i'm here
anyways this is where else am i gonna go
i'm just gonna really and that's when
you step to the next level and that's
when you step in the cage i'm here to
fight anyway i might as well win you
know it's it's that's the simple thing
it's such a great feeling and this works
for if you're a [ __ ] salesman yeah
the same thing as a salesman anything
[ __ ] in three [ __ ] weeks you know
what this is the week if i don't sell
[ __ ] i'm quit
then you call some [ __ ] who not
only buys from you but buys 80 [ __ ]
thousands of those things
and you were ready to quit yeah you're
ready to [ __ ] quit in the words of
sheryl crow why quit before what's he
saying quit before the dream happens
what are the [ __ ] says
so how does now how the [ __ ] does bj and
all these people come in when do they
come in how's your fighting yeah well
basically when i'm on to camp i'm
fighting i opened my school in 1995 in
las vegas uh still open
um and it was it was really cool because
in 93 the ufc started joyce gracie was
kicking everybody's ass and um and i
opened my school in 95 and there was no
jiu-jitsu hardly anywhere in the world
not to mention um in las vegas and
nevada so i had the very first mma
brazilian jiu-jitsu school in nevada so
every time he won a fight the next day
my school was packed you know they had
nowhere else to go like you said this is
it how many schools are there now
probably i couldn't even begin to even
tell you like you said it's like a seven
eleven there's four
there's one
there's four within
ten minutes of a right now yeah yeah
that's on the safe side four good ones
uh gracie barra alberto crane
no but i'm saying it's not like
low levels
marcelo over here
uh a jack jack black belt
he's in burbank from here right on
koenga
and uh
the guy in santa monica he's a hegan
black belt
on fourth street they have street sports
yeah i know there's also like verdums
down there too for dooms down there too
you know but no he has a school in
sherman hawks the partner has a little
school writing sherman
sherman oaks bjj random ventura so yeah
yeah and there's a million million
affiliate schools like you're saying
that aren't even
great but they're still jiu jitsu
schools mma schools everywhere so yeah
but back to your question you i'm so
basically open school um i'm fighting
i'm doing really well um so i started
attracting
people you know they like how i fight
and they come to vegas they try the
school they train with me and they're
hooked and then uh it gets better and
better and then um chuck liddell
basically a friend the same guy one cake
nick nick plumgren he uh he brings chuck
to me and says chuck's gonna fight in
the ufc you know he's a kickboxer
he wants to work on his grappling and
ground and stuff could you help
so i started training chuck for his
first fight and i was with him for his
first 12 years from then on you know i
trained him from the very beginning when
he was making a thousand bucks a fight
and you know and i was so hackeman was a
striking guy yeah from youth even way
younger than that even yeah but but even
during the first part of the ufc um john
wasn't there as much but then you know
he started picking up and then john was
always there but yeah ackerman was
always been when he was young guy is
stand-up coach so i was his brilliant
jiu-jitsu coach and grappling coach in
general he was a great wrestler but that
but we worked with with him for the
first few years if you watch his fights
he's just the kind of guy you couldn't
keep him on the ground you know you even
if you get chucked to the ground he's
right back up on his feet and that's
what we worked on and that's what my
specialty was as an instructor from
martial art fighters is that
i don't i don't
bring you to me and say
just start learning my my moves or my
way and this is this is all you're going
to do because that would be
very generic you know that's that's what
a lot of schools do in jiu jitsu they
teach i would take the individual chuck
for instance who could wrestle and who
could and he could strike good and even
though my specialty was brazilian jiu
jitsu i've experienced in a lot of other
arts at the time black couple two black
belts in shogundo and other things i
would say you need to first of all not
even do jiu jitsu you need to first of
all know how to defend jiu-jitsu and you
know how to get back up so you can
strike again so the first couple years
my biggest focus was simply getting off
your back and getting back to your feet
to do what you're already good at
then over time we'll build
you taking the guy down and passing his
guard and you know but the big concern
was to fill immediately fill holes that
can help him fight now and get better
and that's what i could do for anybody
if i'd get a grappler who's really good
on the ground but he can't take guys
down then i'd be focusing on wrestling
taking him down takedowns how to use the
stand up the basics the hands whatever
just to get to a situation that he can
get the guy in the ground so i was very
very good at strategy and i'm very very
good at helping people um understand
you know what they need you know and i
was i'm called one of the first mixed
martial artists because
besides being in the very beginning of
the game fighting
i was one of the very few people that
had um black belts in a lot of different
arts and was very well versed so i was
able to take people out of their element
if i fought a boxer i'd wrestle them if
i had a wrestler i'd box them if i
thought you know i didn't have to just
do at that exact same time it was poised
fighting jiu-jitsu against wrestling you
did too against kickboxing i was i could
do all of it so i when i fought the
gracie kid i was a g i was very good in
judith already but so was he so that
fight was me mostly staying on my feet
and using my hands even when i took him
down i did real well but i'm like i know
he cannot box with me you know i know
i'm a better athlete than he was so i
was able to in the very beginning change
that a lot you know change the game and
become a martial artist it was a mixed
martial artist before there was a term
for that you know
and then it goes on and on into the
story of of how the fritidas and dana
white and everybody even
got interested in buying the ufc and how
i trained them and and all that which is
part of why they say what you said
earlier about my legacy with the sport
is literally i put together the scenario
that helped
the fertittas make that purchase and
move on into
buying the ufc and at that time the show
was pretty much dead in the water so my
affiliation with dana and the fertitta
brothers training them for years
privately before they
bought um the ufc and bringing chuck and
bringing tito and introducing them to
all these people simply because i wanted
to make the private more exciting so i
bring bj penn and i bring chuck liddell
as my friends
it got them so
they they fell in love with the sport
and through that you know meant the you
know the tap out guys meant you know the
ufc owners and everybody and and it
and they're making becoming what it is
today so i had a big hand in um
you know getting it where it was i
believe when i was with lorenzo fertitto
at first he was on the boxing commission
and he was one of the ones that was
trying to keep the ufc from coming to
las vegas because it was hurting it
would hurt the boxing game
you know he went from that to resigning
as chairman and buying the ufc through
our two years together you know
it's [ __ ] interesting
that really is interesting
it's kind of cool how
you you would think
well like i i have to beat them at what
i like what we're both good at but
why why put yourself through that that
pain
and then sometimes fighters get get
knocked for like it wasn't it like
brendan's job at a metamoris or
something he just like laid on the
ground like he wouldn't
he wouldn't attack and did it he'd only
defend yeah yeah and people spectators
get mad but as a digital person like
he's really good when i attack
why would i why would i put myself in
danger like that well you know you don't
think it's funny you say that because
there's this thing about
the sport right now it's evolved into an
exciting place because everybody's so
well-rounded they can't stand they can
grapple they can wrestle and stuff but
when i was training tito um
i mean he didn't have his title yet and
i trained him all the way through his
title with when he fought vandalism in
japan and i was there in the corner and
i developed a strategy the strategy to
renovate soba good friend of mine he
comes forward just one two one two
forward and very aggressive forward
and he commits and he has bad intentions
when he throws his punches to me bad
intentions mean two things one if he
hits me i'll knock me out two he's going
to over commit so i can take advantage
of that
so tito being a great wrestler the whole
strategy for me for tito is basically go
out like you're going to step in front
of him give throw a couple techniques to
make him standing to make him want to
punch with me just to get his go get him
going as soon as he commits shoot under
him take him down ground and pound them
they'll stand you back up again just do
it over and over and over and for the
whole fight he did that for five rounds
dominated every round um and you know
some people said man all they did was
take the guy down and didn't but it
doesn't matter you know what because he
won the title and from that day forward
became t ortiz that we know today the
champion you know so
they can grumble they can say what they
want because they're sitting in this
they're sitting out there watching never
even trained most of the guys a lot of
them are 16 but truth of matter is tito
had to to make a career for himself and
win and as a fighter you do what you
have to do to win and that's based on
strategy and that was the right strategy
for that fight
so it's it's really uh
it really isn't a tour a mature mind
they can make those decisions and now
you get caught up in
trying to make everybody else happy you
got to make yourself happy and you got
to feed your family first
it's it's messed up because it is a
business so
as a fan you want like every fight to be
like two nick diaz's against each other
of course you do yeah so uh does that
play into that at all with the fighters
when like their ufc's renegotiating
their contracts or they'll give you more
money if you're more entertaining what
they did is they they did those those um
bonuses
yeah knockout of the night submission of
the night that was how they did that and
that's what they're that's what their
answer to that was just to get it more
exciting let's pay people you know 70
000 more if they do a
great submission and that's enough to
incentivize somebody especially when the
money's okay you know so
that was uh that was what they did
you're right when i used to walk out of
higgins and i'd see you teaching the mma
classes and one day it was just you and
a dude and you said leave your gear
don't worry about just leave your
[ __ ] gear let's do this and he's like
well i don't know and you like just
[ __ ] lead the gear and you would
teach them
and i've been putting on my shoes
thinking how [ __ ] interesting is this
that this guy it's just
another guy would maybe come in and
stretch and put you through the [ __ ]
nonsense the kid was already warm you
jumped on and i was like so interested
that this guy
has worked with chuck liddell he's
worked with bj penn he's worked with
tito
but he takes five minutes out to help a
kid that's laying in this [ __ ] class
that's why you're sitting where you're
sitting by the way
because i think uh
if i took the money away from this
you'd still do this 100
when i was fighting with two places yeah
and it's i gotta tell you man i love
doing stand-up counting you know when i
hate it
when it's for money
when i go to the comedy store and i do
those 20 minutes at night
they pay me 15
and my dick gets hard
my dick gets hard i don't have to worry
about it i don't think about it
sometimes i pick up my check sometimes
i've never gone in there looking for a
check of course the manager will see me
go
and he'll just give us a bunch of checks
the other day i was standing at the bar
with joe
and the manager gave him checks and
joe's like i never even take these
like they just go right back they revert
you know like you don't even think about
it that's not why my heartburn is when i
have to get on a plane and
do a door deal and worry about how many
people in the audience i got to take lee
with me to count that's not stand up
yeah that's something else you know
what happened to the days where i gave
you a buck and a half and i [ __ ]
showed up twice a week and you threw me
through the wall
and at the end we stretched it and
that's
i hate everything you know that's
corporate america yeah today
that's it you know if
uh
i'm not saying nothing bad i'm just
saying something like uh
i just said that gracie bar you know
their reunion they do whatever the [ __ ]
they do you know
uh
if i'm a kid and i'm not i don't have
rich parents you know they charge 180 a
month i think that's 180 for a ghee or
whatever it is you know
if if
if i don't have the dough i can't go
there you know because it's corporate
that's what the rates are on paper
but a guy like you you've been on the
other side of the track okay you know
what yeah
just leave that sneak of what you got
every month and i'll take it
you want to learn this guy really wants
to learn with the other guy you know
it's just
business side to art always sucks for me
it sucks dick for me
it makes me feel shitty sometimes when i
i just can't walk in there and do a gig
and just [ __ ] go home yeah you know
money and art to me have never really
it's a part that you
you want to do but because you know what
some guy will give you all the dough in
the world coming training say to you
halfway hey hold on i gotta take a call
yeah
somebody will come and give you 15
and he's dead 10 minutes before the
class now he's already done 10 push-ups
before you [ __ ] walk through the
doors you know that's worth my time yeah
that's the one that you're like you know
what come next week well i can only come
once a week because my parents can't
afford it just come [ __ ] next week
exactly we'll work it out
you'll clean the [ __ ] bathroom you'll
do whatever you want to do what is your
vision for this new place this is
hollywood you know you're in hollywood
uh as you know a lot of fighters have
relocated to los angeles you know uh
southern california is it this is it
right you know jersey's great but
you know you got a enzo and you got a
the kid down in henry what's this what's
the brazilian henry with tom where
frankie edgar goes albert uh
the other guy alberto he lost the ufc
crane is here
crane's here
alberto he trains in jersey and henry
new jersey doesn't matter he's a black
belt out there right sarah's a little
great man but uh good guys you got you
got my man marcelo garcia in new york
you got draculino on [ __ ] new
york city so new york's bouncing with
jiu jitsu but this is it yeah you know
the word on the street is you know
mexico's got jon jones down there but
this is it you got
you got the schools in san diego you got
the schools in orange county which are
top notch you got great trainers i mean
uh
what do you want to do
well this school this school here you
know the unbreakable performance and
it's beautiful everything's [ __ ]
popping on the top of the line
everything partners jay glazer from fox
and then brian urlacher from chicago
bears
um and it's so basically it's everything
in this place equipment wise just for
conditioning is top notch i mean crying
machines from hyperbaric chambers and i
mean it's top of the notch as far as
that goes so we have clients like you
know usher and army hammer and uh jeremy
piven and you know a great
as well as every nfl you can see just
training there on a normal basis just
normal cool people just training you
know and then we have um the classes as
well now so basically i came in and i
opened all the martial arts side of it
you know so we're doing all that stuff
kids classes starting as well
and uh my goal is really used to to
build build a quality high-end um
uh martial art facility that really
people can get what they pay for you
know not just
you know it it costs what it cost but to
make sure people leave saying thank you
that for i'm happy to pay this because
you're giving me what i'm paying people
people don't mind paying for something
good if they really get what it's worth
you know and paying for someone's name
is one thing which is a lot of people do
in town you know you i get to train with
so and so but nothing's better than
someone paying and being grateful
because it was such a good class and
that's my goal if i don't leave the
class with people saying
man thank you so much i get every time i
leave a class i get texts from everybody
saying i'm so great to train with you
john but you know it's just
they're not saying it because i'm john
because there's a lot of those guys in
town like you said in this block we have
a bunch of those great names it's
because the class was was rewarding and
they felt that i really wanted to be
there like you said and i do really want
to be there so i just simply want to
build a great school here
a great team um you know we have
privates kids you know adult classes
everything you can think of just even
just the conditioning is great there as
well and just do that thing you know not
and then you know my other passion which
is of course very very important to me
is my acting career which is why i left
vegas to come here but gosh you know i'm
in hollywood training producers and
directors so it all works hand in hand
you know hold that thought where's tony
bennett cox you're sitting there
meditating thinking about the mexican
girlfriend how you gonna tear up this
weekend i saw that you're thinking about
how you ate a star with me and then
pulled out
that the chocolate
milligrams i got a piece you know
it's sugar-free that's what i want you
to try
oh god but tony bennett
what
are you kidding me or what
[ __ ] john lewis is a savage and [ __ ]
[ __ ] be flying through windows
and [ __ ]
a nice break
what the [ __ ] this is how we do it yeah
i like this
uh
what do you think of the whole acting
[ __ ] thing
well listen i like it i'll tell you why
as you know i explained came from vegas
is a dancer i was a guy on stage but
from that to becoming you know the what
i wanted to be is the rock star the lead
guy the lead guy in the band not the
drummer you know the guy you know and i
went from that into doing you know i own
my own fighting shows my own fighting
organizations as the promoter and did
all that and then uh then i have have
had and have an amazing business um you
know celebrity talent booking agency
marketing director for casinos and clubs
and you know so i've always been
the guys an entrepreneurial guy that's
always the guy but always likes to be
the guy in front so i enjoy
acting i look at it as a new craft the
same way i did i i found something i
love again like martial arts you know
where i really love the the craft itself
and studying and understanding the craft
and talking with you know actors like
yourself that has such experience and
that is that that really moves me the
way that someone coming to train with me
and jiu-jitsu would move them and i i'm
happy to be very talented as an actor i
think and uh i've been doing very well
so
that's to me that's i love it actually
did you go to acting classes
do you still go different places yeah
yeah trade
method right now with someone um down in
uh santa monica side okay yeah some from
from the actual from this actor studio
in new york but um you know also uh you
know aaron spiezer trained his school
his place for a while and a master class
there and did the growlings classic
courses and all those different things
and uh but a lot a lot of my you know
with mickey my train mickey work as well
so i learned a lot from mickey yeah and
he's been very very helpful and uh
generous with his knowledge you know as
well so i just you know i can learn from
watching i mean i watch movie after
movie after movie and i pay attention
and i just and i excel quickly and
things um so
you know to me that's it's my new
my new passion you know it's funny
because
the type of community i consider myself
as like an mma fighter because
i could act i could act as [ __ ] i love
it i especially now like uh
now i'm to a point where i'm very
fortunate when i get on the set i know
exactly what to do from a to z and lee
and i have had this conversation that
very early i was very lucky i got big
movies you know a day here two days here
which you watch you unless you're a
[ __ ] momo you sit there and you watch
what people do and then you emulate it
you emulate you put a touch of yourself
yeah and then uh
the most shocking thing happened i i
also when i first got here i got a
couple big things
and then but i wanted to get good like
everybody else so every wednesday at
five o'clock i was on 7-eleven on sunset
and gardener and i would get the
backstage and i would run home with that
night i'd go out and get all [ __ ] do
stand up but when i got home i got a
[ __ ] grandma blow and i do the coke
and i do the submissions for backstage
and i'd stay up till 6 and i'd get all
creepy and walk to the post office and
mail them and then that night or the
next day they would call me first
because those small movies
always only call three people per
character they're small they don't even
pay half the time i just wanted to do it
and work to get good to get a real
because at this time you can't do dick
without a reel
and i kept doing that doing this and
then i locked down then you start
[ __ ] booking i booked a couple improv
shows i booked mad tv i booked a half
hour sitcom i booked some [ __ ] dramas
you know i booked movies as dramas as
comedy you know i like doing the drama
better than the [ __ ] comedy because
on the comedy i'm on a hook i'm on a
hook i gotta do this [ __ ] on a drama i
just gotta smack somebody or fly through
a wall and get beat up we got a
handcuffed that's my specialty get
drilled by a cop you know
and now like when i did marin in
brooklyn 99 last year and [ __ ] like that
right i just felt you know i wasn't uh i
would get that i'd feel my natural
insecurity
which that always comes out but then
after a couple minutes i go why am i
insecure
i paid my [ __ ] rent right not the
[ __ ] white belt with a striper
this [ __ ] i'm sitting right in
this [ __ ] middle here
and having that attitude lifts you 100
it lifts you that's it like when i did
marron i looked around marin is the show
when i moved here you know what's the
show that premiered last night i saw
very close okay when i first got to this
town you know what the hot show was in
town his show
with the other guy breaking bad no no
this is [ __ ] 18 years ago he had a
show on hbo
with the dude with the glasses and [ __ ]
and every agent you talk to
when you went to their office in those
days and say you're a comedian what do
you think of this show you're like oh
these two [ __ ] guys and you couldn't
call an agent after 4 30 on a certain
two days because they were taping the
show so every [ __ ] agent went to the
show well that show now is married
everybody goes to mary every agent so
i'm sitting there getting my hands and i
said [ __ ] i'm taking it to the [ __ ]
hoop that's why i'm married i'm snorting
blowing the episode i'm going great
they're like we don't want you to do it
but we want you know we have vitamin b
here give me the [ __ ] thing fill it
up watch me snort vitamin b [ __ ]
and you just go you know and i went home
that night going you know what
i'm not just a comic anymore yeah i was
[ __ ] laughs
then you want to write and that's the
completion that's the three disciplines
mixed into the [ __ ] one
you know some mornings i wake up and i
write a chapter in a book some mornings
i wake up and i write [ __ ] three
[ __ ] jokes you know yeah i'm writing
and producing and all of it are writing
the scripts and i'm producing feature i
mean with my business background that i
have you know i'm capable of i don't i'm
not the guy that sits there waiting for
my agent to call me and give me an
audition like a lot of the things i've
got i've just been my own networking and
my own abilities and uh and and i want
to write pieces that i like that i want
to be in i'll put myself in a scenario
in there where i'm working with the the
right people around me that's going to
help elevate my game but make sure
they're where they need to be so i can
make my money back and uh you know i get
the business and i understand it very
well and uh i love the craft man you
know and leading man is where i want to
be not just you know act but i want to
[ __ ] once again i want to be the lead
singer of the band i don't want to be
the drummer you know
i always uh
thought about musicians that came out
did what you did had a leader hell i'm a
great album an arm that sold
you know and then one day just said [ __ ]
i don't want to do this no more remember
vh1 had that show where they show where
are they now yeah and they showed some
pretty badass [ __ ] who took
that money and opened up a painting
company mm-hmm and so i always wanted to
paint the houses and then i paint houses
you're like what the [ __ ] you with a man
[ __ ]
what were you thinking but you know i
think i can do the same thing every
[ __ ] week i'm like
every time i go somewhere with my wife
and i get pissed off now
a restaurant or something i could i
should just do this and shut my [ __ ]
mouth to show these [ __ ] how
it's done just i went up a competing
restaurant yeah like [ __ ] all these
[ __ ] up yeah man i had to go to my
wife with her friends yesterday and the
kids to eat cuban food i'm [ __ ] cute
these people were insulting me i mean
i didn't wait i think it's my turn how
did you get stuck with all that
well you got going with your wife's
friends to go to cuban food oh i love my
wife and he said i know i know i know
the girl the girl's cuban her husband is
an actor great dude the kids are
beautiful i wanted to go too
but when i went it was the place we went
it keeps getting worse and [ __ ] worse
i got to bring my own [ __ ] hot sauce
and [ __ ] nobody has frank's [ __ ] hot
sauce out here in california i'm a
franks type of [ __ ]
on my [ __ ] is frank's cuban no frank is
[ __ ] a white dude from buffalo he
invented the wing [ __ ] sucker that's who
frank this is
frank's hot sauce and [ __ ] louisiana
style hot sauce but why would they have
that at the cuban restaurant because
that's what you [ __ ] that's what it
calls for it doesn't call for tapatio
[ __ ] that's for mexican food dog i'm not
insulting though but i'm just telling
you you got to pick a [ __ ] flag
that's why i don't go to chinese
japanese restaurants [ __ ] you [ __ ] pick
a [ __ ] flag you can't do both you
can't do pork fried rice and sell
[ __ ] sushi that ain't kosher
that ain't [ __ ] kosher ass any jew
you can't mix fish and [ __ ] walk like
that though
no i'm sorry i think i've got it
yeah they're trying to [ __ ] with cuban
food it [ __ ] pisses me off yeah now
but like you said like what you said
earlier it's like when it comes to the
money and business and acting it's like
whatever it is you're doing it's any
good entrepreneur or any real legitimate
successful entrepreneur will tell you
that you
you just do what you're going to do and
you do it the best you possibly can and
the money will come you don't do it for
the money you know you focus on what
you're trying to do that you you have a
passion for that you love and you do it
the best you can do it and then the
money will come if you're doing it right
was that
for you was it that way for like the
entire time or did you have a switch
because
when you're young it seems like
at least for me it's like all about the
money and because like
you have all these bills depending on
was it a switch like at what point were
you like okay
i don't the money's not here so i'll
just keep doing it i mean still got
bills to pay you know but
but you get you got to love what you're
doing you got to love what you're doing
you know and then and uh
and then it's not work i don't get up in
the day going i have a full day of
things that i'm doing for the goals that
i'm trying to achieve and trust me we
could if i told you them all you think i
was all over the place although it all
makes perfect sense to me but it's it's
uh every one of them are something i
look forward to waking up the next day
to do because it's something i love you
know and if you do it right then
you know the reaper questions come
you know you just had a belief
i told a thousand stories on here when i
lived in an office i lived in an office
that was after this in seattle a buck
and a quarter of a month
there was no bathroom you had to piss
out the [ __ ] window
i had to use to take showers at the gym
down the street
i'd go in there twice a day go in the
morning and work out take a shower you
know
that's when you know how much you love
something because at that point you go
what am i doing i could move home work
for my dad at the gas station make a ton
of loot steel
[ __ ] driver's car and but you're like
[ __ ] that yeah this is what i want to do
this is what i believe yeah
it's a rough belief man it's uh
it's tough to sell to people people
can't sell it to themselves and that's
why
just like you you know you have that
picture of you i don't know how many
years ago i had to be 15 rico and
a chuck with hair
and
tito so they were close that's when
what the [ __ ] you know what do you say
15 years later you see these guys
chuck went on to become one of the
greatest [ __ ]
chuck inspired me i went back and joined
kempo and lost 100 pounds because of
chuck i get it whenever chuck's in the
room dog look at my face i'm just
[ __ ] pale
and finally one dad had balls to talk to
him he's very nice yeah he introduced me
to him he's very [ __ ] nice i seen him
do some crazy [ __ ] one time in the ufc
event like he just knocked somebody out
he just knocked somebody out like two
weeks before he walked into an event
with a [ __ ] baby carriage yeah a
little bit it was just
everybody [ __ ] that was howling he
was like what [ __ ] he had this little
baby carriage
yeah he's just a human being like all of
us man paying bills you know
you know like when i when i was fighting
back in the day
to give you an idea the fight with
carlos and gracie jr here's my purse
this is the purse
zero to lose
four thousand dollars if i win the title
on pay-per-view
i i didn't it could have been one
thousand it could have been it would
have made a difference to me because i
wasn't fighting for that reason in those
days i was fighting because i wanted to
see okay i've been fighting in the back
of my yard i teach at my school you know
i had this thing on my flyers it was
anyone six six or taller or 250 or
heavier could train for free with me and
the reason i did that was because i
wanted to fight against them so i'd have
you know all kinds of
people are paying for privates but these
guys could train for free because that
was going to benefit me to test where i
was and then i met a gentleman named
john peretti who was matchmaker for the
ufc extreme fighting and he put me in
some of these real shows when it just
started but to me was like an
opportunity to fight someone who is
definitely worthy of me fighting to see
how good i really was
i really was it was always about to
better myself to see how good i really
was and it's carried over i retired
probably five years before that real
money started in the game you know
because
it was never that's why i started
producing my own show the wfa the world
fighting alliance which the ufc bought
for me
for you know for uh quite a bit of money
three years later i mean but the reason
was because i eventually said okay i'm
not gonna ever make money as fighter
fighters don't make money because
you know now is rough but then was you
could you can't even imagine
top payday in the world for the best
fighter which i was one of them was like
20 grand you know
so i i mean what two times a year or
three hundred i mean what is that you
know so long story short i started my
own show you know and i started and i
had this great concept called the world
fight fighting alliance where the fight
club beats the nightclub and i brought
in uh um john huntington who was a very
popular uh club promoter he did huge
arena shows and i did all the
matchmaking i was the president i put it
all together he made sure that it had
like laser lights and great djs playing
and go-go girls between rounds it was
amazing it was amazing uh everybody
would be there including the fritids
everybody would be there and it had it
was 17 and over so it was hot chicks and
it brought a whole nother demographic it
was like going out it was like going out
to like a party a nightclub the fights
that were really good and my fight i
mean it was rich franklin frank trigg
and marvin eastman i mean it was real it
was top level what is this this is a
gosh man um
i don't know 15 20. you can google it i
don't even remember yeah sounds like fun
yeah it was amazing but it was and after
four shows the ufc uh bought it from me
they bought it out and we had rampage
and they bought the contract and all
that stuff too so but but yeah that was
my thing and then from there what was
really interesting is i went into um
the nightclub ministry because the
gentleman i was producing with he uh
said hey um you know i'm doing this
little
uh night over at the palms yeah once a
week you can come be a you know club
promoter guy there with me and it'd be
kind of fun i'm like what do i do and
he's like just you know just invite
people get them on a guest list bring
them in you can have a table in bottles
so i'm going there and i and i started
inviting people and and the turnout i
had was hundreds and hundreds of people
would come and i'd realized you know my
my success from the the
fighting really carried over it's like
if oscar de la hoya invited you to a
party you know you came so i was like
man this is so easy people were tons of
people were coming and it was and you
know of course i was just you know
having my table in bottles and making a
couple hundred bucks for the night
nothing serious and uh and basically it
was just it was popping off and then
eventually the individual had a my
partner had a problem with the hotel
they
um you know they this would have hold
deal fell apart years later when we were
the number one spot in vegas and within
three weeks it was dead and that they
couldn't keep it going because so
obviously it was us but so they called
me instead and said hey listen you were
bringing most of the people anyways you
know would you consider taking it over
on your own being your night and i was
like well sure let me check with john
because you know i had loyalty you got
to ask my buddy he's like go for it you
know so within a week and a half it was
popping again more than ever but now i
was it was my thing now and that that
2000 went to 3 000 i mean 200 with the 3
000 a week and then it just continued to
grow until i ended up owning uh and
started this company john lewis
entertainment group which is still in
existence now it's an international
company that deals with thousands of
clubs booking celebrity appearances
internationally um and doing marketing
for big casinos but it just snowballed
and it never was my plan but you know
it's just
doing things that you love you know if
you do it right it just
you know the fruits come you know and
that's how i've been i've been i
you'd be surprised at all the different
full life careers i've been coming to
this point you know you brought
something interesting up i always wanted
to learn i always forget to ask like
when rich franklin who do we have not
rich franklin yeah
what's the reason i love everybody yeah
what's french man what the [ __ ] am i
thinking it was ratchet we've had mma
junkie and we've got you know i gotta
ask you a question i've never asked
anybody
i'm a hot ufc guy
i see the breakdown
like two days later i'll tell you what
each fighter made and that's just a
percentage because that's not their
sponsors or whatever
let's pretend i make uh 25 000 for the
fight and i got a fifty thousand dollar
fight bonus that's seventy five thousand
dollars okay
i walk into [ __ ] uh
your school
and i go take me to the [ __ ] moon
you covered me for jiu jitsu
you hooked me up with some dude from
muay thai
uh you hooked me up with dave for
conditioning
when i get to 75 000 what do i owe you
10 usually so 7 500 yeah so for eight
weeks i give you a measly [ __ ] 75
well you're talking about the best case
scenario the real the truth of the story
is about say you got a school that's
based on fighters you got one or two
guys fighting in the ufc and you had a
bunch of guys that are fighting for 200
bucks a week training for two months
before the fight so obviously it's not
about the money because what 10 percent
of what 500 bucks right for two months
exactly so so it's it's like that but
even worse you know so i thought the
trainer made like 30 percent maybe a lot
more but not i mean you can make 10 or
15 or whatever but it's not a lot more
than that you know because there's still
a manager there's a trainer the same as
the business that we know
there's always different you know
there's a lawyer if you're trying to get
prevented professional
so it all it's once again even though
the fighters they're making okay money
they're they're divvying it up you know
it's been divvied up you know you look
at the
again i'm a [ __ ] freaking you know
because
i'm a comic so i want to see gates you
know i'm always interested in gates
you know my business my family business
when you came from cuba was the gate on
the track you know the numbers in new
york city's the last three numbers of
the power mutuals what the track made
for the [ __ ] day
so every night they'll tell you after a
ufc fight we've made [ __ ] three
million dollars you know what i'm saying
so now you're telling me on the other
hand then i make that much money and i
know there's [ __ ] tons of cars man
when you're pulling a fight people don't
no i mean every time you see that ufc
commercial pop up during [ __ ]
uh abc sports
you know on abc at six o'clock they
[ __ ] pay for that they pay off the
[ __ ] ass yeah and you know they do a
great job of [ __ ] marketing they get
it out there you pop you if you click
onto one ufc post that's it every time
you [ __ ] click onto something umc's
lingering you can be something about
people dying a [ __ ] gonorrhea and the
ufc's in the corner they'll pop up
something [ __ ] crazy it's amazing
there's a ton of [ __ ] money they put
their name out there man
so you know and that's what i always get
pissed off and people raise their hand
that they don't get paid enough
but on the other hand i know that
there's a lot of cost involved as a
comic it's like you said to me joey you
sold this many tickets in this town why
don't you just do a theater because it
becomes something else
what if i do do the [ __ ] see the
comedy club is a built-in thing location
all they got to do is drive they give me
a percentage blah blah blah but if
theater it's all me if a theater is
eight to ten and i go long to a15 guess
what i'm paying for [ __ ] two hours
but i only did 15 minutes it don't
matter to two hour increments read the
[ __ ] contract right you know there's
a thousand [ __ ] costs you know yeah
and that's what joe public has never
really taken into consideration when the
people start raising their hand that's
something different but that's what you
agreed upon yeah you know the thing is
that you know there's different
conversations with this and these are
it's always touchy for me because i'm
you know on both sides of the game i'm a
businessman i've owned my own shows
absolutely but i'm also the fighter that
wants to be paid for what i'm worth yeah
and and i i see all the sides of it you
know i definitely think
uh you know we should work towards the
fighters getting paid more and more but
at the same time you're right and and
also this is a a business that that you
that the differentiators bought
to run as a business you know and they
spent two million dollars of their own
money when it was gone and how much it
cost to buy
and before it when they were just about
to quit and i was there through all of
this they had spent 47 million in
advertising trying to make it go from
the most bloody sport in the world to
the sexiest sport in the world doing fhm
ads rolling stone ads just so much
marketing they were literally saying
we let's throw the towel in and that
forrest griffin fight happened and the
bonner fight and and all of a sudden a
spark of life showed that maybe we
should hang a little longer and now here
we are so
it's just so much money you're right
going in to make this thing what it is
today if they didn't do that
the fighters would be making nothing
because probably ufc wouldn't have
lasted would have been gone you know so
but it's easy to forget that over time
and the next the next thing about it is
it is very expensive uh to to run a show
um i don't know exactly their
percentages are who's being paid what
but
the real problem with the with the show
is
the uh the monopoly they've had on the
business
mean you know being that it was very
it's
you you didn't wanna you don't wanna be
the one that that gets on the bad side
when the only show in town is that
because what's your other option so it's
it's easy to control um
contracts and purses and things of that
nature when there's nothing else but the
game's changing there's no debalator now
there's a world series of fighting now
they're actually contenders you know
bellator is going to be around so um
that's going to help the game a lot
because there is another another option
and those things over time are going to
naturally help you know but if people
compare to them in nfl or to boxing and
how much guys how much money people make
in boxing right but let's think how how
long boxing's been around and but it
seems like it seems like ufc is way more
popular than boxing yeah but my point is
that my mother's not that my point is
that if you're judging
apples and apples
you're judging a sport that's the ufc
bought like maybe 15 years ago the
potatoes bought you know it went from
pretty much zero to this in that amount
of time even though it's been around
before that and you're saying they
should be making the same amount of
money as
uh you know boxers but that sport's been
around forever and by the way amateur
fighters fight for free a lot and
sometimes for 200 bucks in boxing you
know or the lower level fighters just
pacquiao and you know maybe what the
main fights getting the big chunks
because they they drop they draw the the
purse so
you know there's a lot of there's a lot
of there's a lot of sides to it like
you're trying to say it's not as cut and
dry as it seems like oh it's not i do
kind of like it
it's a [ __ ] business
you know what listen i love to [ __ ]
go through my records
and see who [ __ ] short chains me
and go back and say hey [ __ ] you
chore changed me 10 years ago i'm gonna
take you to court and all that stuff
but you know what at the time that's a
deal i took yeah you took the deal
somebody came up to me about a year ago
and said you know what your cd cells
when you go to the army
over there in [ __ ] uh
iran iraq they have little [ __ ] huts
and people go in there and buy stuff and
commissaries and your some cd i did with
jeff garcia and felipe's over there they
sold 400 000 copies of that [ __ ] cd
you know how much i got 1500 that's what
i agreed to
that's what i agreed to yeah and my
coked up mine that was going to save me
so i knew what i was doing at the time i
know i was going to get [ __ ] in the
ass
but i did it anyway right and it happens
in every industry music
music
every industry i i just read this book
my friend mauricio alvarado about black
sabbath that didn't make no money
nine albums eight albums didn't make a
[ __ ] dime
the guy would give him a car from time
to time he'd think i put your car
there's a car around the corner and
you know think of the people who got
robbed but
in your haze and your love for what
you're doing it's just not the
i don't know when you're involved in
something this is what you do yeah then
years later you wake up and you get
pissed off or whatever right you all
have bad feelings let me give some shout
outs yeah
and we'll get you the [ __ ] out of here
what's up with you dracula look at you
give me the evil eye the [ __ ]
absolutely you have like a buffet going
on edibles today
i just uh this is what they gave me you
know that's the scariest bag in the
world
what are you gonna do you know i don't
travel light
i got time to dilly dally i'm like
[ __ ] john lewis over here
do you ever sleep
i don't i can't i can't imagine you
don't sleep yeah i think you take a
special shot that gives you like five
minutes of sleep and you're good but i
do sleep for like four or five hours and
i'm happy and i'm good
five hours but not like i just wake up
and i'm ready to work i'm ready to start
my day and do something he thanks the
lord
yeah dilly dally he ain't playing
[ __ ]
call for duty
he lives it you know what i'm saying why
[ __ ] play call of duty when you can
live it jump off a [ __ ] building
and start your goddamn day
stuart cole out there in london i love
you [ __ ] happy birthday i know
it's something going on with you i just
forgot right now
lloyd uh the fly the wave
blake mayor juan juniors ricky mclean
aaron heath radcliffe gaddis yates
radcliffe yates
clayton
webb
ryan cavazos down there i'll see you
next week doug sucker alex z
and james hewlett stay black you [ __ ]
you know i love you
what's up what are you looking at me all
creeped up for
did your eyelids finally look as [ __ ]
up as mine
you called me and said people were at
the dispensary and they were asking if
these were the stars that you give me
[ __ ] up all right that's right two
little [ __ ] killing me
i gotta do it john now he sits around he
don't wanna do nothing he plays that
[ __ ] call of duty six hours a day
i'm gonna blow up that [ __ ] game one
of these days i call them in the morning
what are you doing uh when is the grand
opening my brother
we're gonna call we're gonna pick a hard
grand opening in the next few weeks i'd
like to definitely let everybody know
they'll look up some of the social media
to follow that and find out let them
know let them know if you don't mind no
no no no no yeah so i'm i'd love you
guys to come follow me on twitter um
it's just at john lewis mma real easy um
you can kind of see all the updates and
what i'm up to and uh followed the
everyday exploits of uh striving
entrepreneur and um and facebook um it's
just
forward slash john lewis fighter
instagram john those mma as well and the
website is
johnlewismma.com so it's all pretty easy
but you can see we're open now you can
come train now you can come into the
school uh you can find the information
on the website um
there's also a number you can call
my partner david and his number is three
one zero
two five eight
eight that number's for taking uh giving
you more information about the school
but coming is signed up and then when
the grand opening happens we'll have
chuck there and tito there and i mean
randy and everyone i mean everybody will
be there and it's going to be a real big
shindigs [ __ ] savage him saying lee's
going to come down he's going to do some
jumping a little bit of rolling lisa
savage cryo machine and you have no idea
he's a wrestler in high school state
championship no
man oh i was never waiting let me
[ __ ] the man shut your [ __ ] mouth
i'm trying to tell you
i can't tell you open your eyes to open
your eyes that's not going to happen
look at this what do you got the rest of
the day
no nothing that's why i went to the gym
before this because i knew i was gonna
get [ __ ] up how many calories you got
left
huh how many calories you got left i
don't know i haven't put them all in yet
we got this crown machine over there
it's awesome it like takes you down to
minus 240. oh degrees for like for like
two minutes but it burns 900 calories
just standing still what it's and it
also is great for your joints and
everything for 900 calories standing
still and still so it's uh so yeah you
can come down here
you can take one of those things come
down just stand burn 900 calories and
then you go and watch the call of duty
so two minutes just stay there
well it's not that easy it's cold but
like above the floor
i don't make it how cold is it going to
200 but wait a second a minute it's 450
that's what you got to stand on that
bicycle for an hour before i know wait
so how long could you stay there could i
see that for like an hour a day you
probably didn't get frostbite
[ __ ] that lee you can do it you're from
boston you ain't no [ __ ] 900 calories
right you wait a minute
that would take me like an hour and a
half wait how many [ __ ] tell him who
needs the snow is falling like six foot
my mom my mom keeps shuffling
my younger brother lives there
and can't they don't they won't let them
like leave
there's a a parking on the street band
there's a driving ban unless you're like
a state employee
so she's been
shoveling every all day every day my
wife left cnn on
and it was on i was in the kitchen with
the baby and i heard
some lady going
it snowed 71 inches in like two weeks or
something [ __ ] ridiculous i'm from
hawaii yeah and i'm hearing this and all
of a sudden like i straighten up and i'm
like what's the [ __ ] [ __ ] there's
always something on tv bitching i did
the math in my head i'm like that's
[ __ ] up yeah like 71 inches in three
days or something i think it's like two
weeks
i think we're like the last one oh my
[ __ ] god and it's 19 degrees this
morning and it's snowing again right now
my friend's like yeah it's 19 degrees
but it's warming up what
what i went to the [ __ ] park with the
baby i had to put shorts on and [ __ ] i
got bit by some bug because i had short
side of the show it's definitely much
better out here yeah no i can't go back
and [ __ ] hawaii they don't even give
a [ __ ]
all you do all day is do a couple
jujitsu eat some pineapple juice
at the beach
i've actually heard from people who like
were born in hawaii
if they were white or like not native
they got they had like they didn't like
it
like
someone who's never been there when you
think hawaii you think like paradise it
would be great to live there but then
i've heard a bunch of people say it's
not that great a place where you don't
think there's a phone i think you have
to fist fights everything yeah that's
what that's what i'm talking about so
he's gonna beat people up you'd be all
good oh god good thing you're a wrestler
no
i was in a couple fights
but no i don't want to be in fights
every week i'm going to kill you in that
[ __ ] car you're going to be drunk
that happens you know listen man it's
tough because sometimes you get sucked
in
i was coming home from the ice house one
night
minding my own business just driving
some guy pulled up next to me and he was
lurking i don't know maybe they have
some people have bad days
you don't know what the [ __ ] they're
going through they had bad days they sat
next to me finally i just you know i was
in the express lane i'm not even
supposed to be in that lane right that's
how late it was it was 10 30 11. i'm not
drinking and driving i don't drink and
drive so i don't even drink so i'm just
driving like something i look at the
[ __ ] give me the [ __ ] finger
i'm like what the [ __ ] did i do and i
kept trying after while i'm like you
know what [ __ ] you [ __ ] and also you
started looking at me giving me like
eyes and shits i had a bunch of pennies
in this tank i opened up my window and i
threw it this way and i heard this car
go
that [ __ ]
drove down that 130 before he didn't
know what you were doing you know it hit
him [ __ ] no and [ __ ] he didn't know what
that was and by the way we'll give you
people a follow-up i haven't talked to
my daughter in like 15 years so oh yeah
it took me like a [ __ ]
six months to draw the courage up to
call the house you know for her birthday
she's 25. okay i haven't talked to she
was like 15 or 16.
so i knew i knew there was going to be
either some type of drama or i wouldn't
hear back from them then i'd get back to
them like a year
with some story or something listen i've
been through all of them
they never called back
not one time they called back not even a
[ __ ] postcard nothing
so now i gotta call them back again i
got like a hundred emails which is very
supportive of your people you're gonna
call them back now yeah i gotta call her
back that's it i gotta [ __ ] reach out
now man oh [ __ ] no i gotta [ __ ] bite
into it this is my kid yeah you gotta do
it gotta do this [ __ ] for a long time i
was scared
i was really like ah you know i don't
wanna call over there but i got the baby
got a two-year-old
and i think every [ __ ] day when i'm
with the two-year-old you know so yeah i
got my six-year-old nothing more
important to me so yeah
you have him yeah my boy three nights a
week yeah yeah and then the other nights
he goes back to vegas no his mom's out
here too oh
support of each other he's in he's
coming back from disney world today then
over there
partying in disneyland disney world i
should say in florida yeah so he's been
having a good few days
vacation [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
i want to give uh my main [ __ ]
over there at irondragontv.com
listen these people ain't [ __ ] around
i got some secrets to tell you in a
couple weeks but iron dragon tv is not
[ __ ] around this just the beginning
[ __ ] all right go to iron
dragon right now for classic martial
arts the other day i was on the el rey
channel and they had the one arm
swordsman the returning one arm swords
and i taped all of it on my and i
remembered how much i enjoyed watching
classic martial arts the movies are so
[ __ ] up and so unbelievable you just
sit there and go what the [ __ ] is
happening
but [ __ ] it this is how good this movie
is
i love it it's this confusion
you don't know what the [ __ ] they're
saying it's over dubbed comfort theater
there was a [ __ ] bomb everywhere yeah
so stop sitting there like a moog oh my
god the academy awards did you see the
grammys [ __ ] you here it is you didn't
go to any grammy party [ __ ] yeah nobody
[ __ ] listen
even if they invited me i wouldn't go
down and walk around and watch kanye
west insulting people i don't need that
[ __ ] in my [ __ ] life you understand
me that's why i kill a chicken once a
month
that's why i kill a chicken once a month
in my backyard i give it to the saints
and they move on i don't need that [ __ ]
sure that's why you're in such good
shape as i pray for you
irondragontv.com you get two free movies
when you put in the box joey oh [ __ ]
j-o-e-y get two free [ __ ] classic
kung fu films they got tons of genre the
ip-man
they got new stuff too and they got new
stuff on a daily number two on it i love
you [ __ ] without you i wouldn't
even live
if it's not the alpha brain the [ __ ]
strong bone the shroom tech immune the
shroom tech sport i get on a plane i pop
two shroom tech communes i can [ __ ]
sit in a toilet seat and rub my dick on
the [ __ ] thing nothing i go home no
rashes no [ __ ] hitch no impressive
impressive no nothing
no ebola i told you this before if you
take [ __ ] shroom tech no ebola
[ __ ] listen do me a favor go to
honor.com right now go through it with
their products there's something you
like there's something not like i can't
get you ten percent off on the ropes and
the [ __ ] kettlebells but as far as
the nutrients i get you ten percent i'll
tell you what i gotta press the church
church
c-h-u-r-c-h in the box you get ten
percent off right you know i don't [ __ ]
around that's how i roll number two hit
e-cigs i'm just smoking a cigar a
[ __ ] day here whether it's the cigar
whether it's a cigarette it comes in 24
16 8 boom there you have it you could
quit in a [ __ ] month you have to hang
out with stinky [ __ ] fingernails you
can't stick your finger up somebody's
ass smells like negative it's terrible
when you can't do that what the [ __ ]
that's the whole patois what i'm saying
when they're sitting there looking like
a popsicle and you're watching espn
who's better than you anyway
headysex.com they ain't [ __ ] around
they also have this cigar if you want to
go to atlantic city and be a big shot
down there with the puerto ricans knock
yourself out go to 86.com right now and
press in joey's church oh [ __ ] bang that
[ __ ] get 20 off you know why
because that's how i roll [ __ ] suckers
sitting there looking like a popsicle
sure if you ever think when you finger
somebody's [ __ ] you're looking like a
popsicle they're frozen oh no
what do you think you're dealing with at
least i'm [ __ ] novice you think i
just wake up and ricky doink on
lancashire all day i'm slinging dick dog
i'm telling you right now oh [ __ ] you
want to smoke that vapor you're sick of
smoking reefer go to nailed it life.com
they'll [ __ ] take care of you they
got pens they got whistles they got
sticks that you can burn but they got
blow torches
listen burn them [ __ ] like rick james i
don't give a [ __ ] you understand me go
to delta life.com they ain't [ __ ]
around they got the best vaper pen in
business they guarantee it and just if
you mentioned
joey diaz oh [ __ ] you get 20 off like a
[ __ ]
that's how we roll over here at church
giving you discounts on vapor pens blow
torches
sticks with
i don't even [ __ ] know
anything's tremendous
one of the best [ __ ] you know what i
love about them the most 1200 guaranteed
pups i'll be smoking this cigar until
the next [ __ ] doomsday you understand
me you know why because it's quality and
that's how i roll high-end dragon tv
what can i say about dave foley knocking
it dead cousins with steve foley from
whoop there it is and honor.com and [ __ ]
right now giving you ten percent off
lead stop rubbing your eyeballs you're
not calling uber look at how high you
are either piece of the cookie i'll
bring it down
it will bring you down
i'm glad you didn't take any because i
feel like you'd lose your
entrepreneurial spirit and you don't
even understand i brought you this
special joint this is
you know this is what they gave
i don't even know what they gave this
burn his eyes
i think smelling salt
i love you john lewis congratulations
the reason why he is because i can tell
you really give a [ __ ] about these kids
you really like what you're doing and
dave
dave's the master disaster dave's gonna
be doing tremendous [ __ ] things lee
what's the story
what's up buddy you're not coming to
austin you're staying home why are you
excited for valentine's tell john
elliott we don't valentine's day he was
the wife john lewis
uh i'll call him john elliott call me
whatever
as long as you call me
but uh
we've been on a diet first like eight
months so we're uh we're going to be
[ __ ] eight pounds at him well
congratulations well thanks but we're
gonna mess it up we're gonna go to uh
we're gonna get a burger from in and out
wings from uh buffalo wild wings and
then uh dessert so you're gonna split a
burger from the night you're not gonna
get a whole one on your own i don't know
probably not yeah buy it and take it out
and bring it to the internet
no we're gonna we're gonna go to all the
places all three places and spend some
time quality time
yeah but we're gonna go see a movie but
there's literally nothing out so i think
we're gonna do something else in between
like what
i think i'm going to take her to the
museum i think
she wants a little action for the car
make out with it
like old school will feel up in tennis
and you get that appetite going
you think you're going to eat a [ __ ]
cheeseburger you're going to be into
your wings 10 minutes later no no it's
all throughout the day it's not like in
an hour like a bunch of plastic gloves
like you were surging this [ __ ]
bring it back to the [ __ ] car and
work that [ __ ] what am i doing
with the plastic gloves nothing you jerk
off and come in your own hand and take
the glove off and you throw it away okay
so your side shows up you're not pulling
an oj what i'm saying i'm just talking
to you here from the heart this is like
a romantic valentine's day it's
valentine's day women like to give hand
jobs they suck dick in cars that's what
they do on valentine's day you're gonna
get her flowers too right yeah okay then
what do you think you just give her the
flowers [ __ ] you put it over your
helmet
as she goes to get the flowers you pick
up the helmet that little jew roll is
out ready to squirt
i love you guys have a great day we'll
be back tomorrow night
stay black stay beautiful thank you john
lewis
don't forget
johnlewismma.com that's where it all
starts go on and see what this
[ __ ] has done he's a true savage
lee get it together all right
go to honor.com jesus christ there we go
this is [ __ ] you can do it you can do it
you can do it you can do it
you can do it
jesus go to honor.com i'm going to mute
you all right go to honor.com use
codeword church to get 10 off of all the
optimization products
i'll tell you something really quick for
you people who kept want to be my
friends on linkedin
nobody all right leave me the [ __ ] alone
every time i get an email i think it's
something important somebody wants to be
my name on linkedin whatever the [ __ ] it
is it's a professional network i want to
know you people because if you're in out
there you don't know nobody anyway leave
me the [ __ ] alone i want to hang out
with another bunch of losers that ain't
working
get the [ __ ] out of here leave me alone
i'm gonna be friends with nobody all
right
everybody always bothers me from that
link thank you john i don't know what
the [ __ ] it is
a network of professionals then what are
you bothering me for
i'm a [ __ ] felon leave me alone
you're not even supposed to be mingling
with me
what the [ __ ] is wrong with people i
hear you man
[ __ ] linkedin hurry up you gotta read
this that's for your next shirt huh [ __ ]
linkedin [ __ ] michael did it
i love these people hopefully people
listen to these
oh you're killing me right now
okay go to irondragontv.com he's come
with joey to get two free rentals of all
the great martial arts movies they have
for all the oil and wax smokers out
there go to nailed it live dot com
and use code joey diaz to get twenty 20
off of the premier vapor pen on the
market and
i'm going to survive and to hit e6.com
better tasting longer lasting proof is
in the vape but they have e-cigarettes
and e-cigars use cobra joey's church to
get 20 off your order
oh [ __ ] we'll be back tomorrow night
[ __ ]
eight o'clock your time hopefully
lee you got to get the roses and put
them by your zipper that's old school or
or before she gets the roses
you got to take your pocket and cut it
off and then put your dick by the pocket
until i go in your pocket to get the car
keys and boom she feels that little
juice stick
it's over you know what i'm saying
it's like a juice linger
that's what we i feel like this is like
the opposite of what they would want
from let's stop will i give you fake
romantic [ __ ] info i think you would
as long as you can reach the pocket you
gotta reach this you gotta be able to
reach the podcast
kick that [ __ ] leak kick that
[ __ ]
this is the devil's cousin playing the
guitar let's do this
oh